if he already makes you happy with how
things are then why do you want to push
it and get married the marriage part is
because i love him and i want to show
him that i love him
just like he showed me
you know i just don't want it to be a
one-way street but it's not a one-way
street mom and you see it you see it
when i talk to him i have to see it when
you're together
i've never seen kimberly so in love with
anybody like she is with usman unless
maybe it was back when she was in high
school i don't want to see her get hurt
because when she puts her
heart into something she puts it in all
the way
i just don't think y'all need to get
married in order for you to show your
love to him cause you could just go
visit him
i want your support so bad unfortunately
i can't bring him here so you can see
what a wonderful guy this is i have to
get him here and in order to do that we
have to be engaged to get him here so he
needs a visa to get here so i mean okay
you all get married or have fun
it's like a light bulb just went off
so you think he's just with me for that
i didn't say that out loud but you just
said a light bulb went off and it's not
just like he's like scamming me to get
the k when i'm the one that brought the
k1 up i brought it up to him
do you think i'm dumb
i just don't think you should rush over
there and propose to him but i feel like
in my heart this is what i want to do
and who knows maybe he'll propose to me
first i mean i don't know i'm going to
meet his mom i have to get her blessing
that's just the way it's done in his
culture you know it's kind of crazy
but if you don't get what if you don't
get her blessing then everything's off i
don't know yet it's ridiculous
but but you know like he loves me
what does he do to show that because i
just being with him like i just the way
he is with me
i think one of my biggest concerns is i
don't really know hussman i've had a few
conversations with him he is an
entertainer and he knows how to get
people on his side he knows the right
things to say
and i just hope my mom can figure out
what is true and what is not
i've just seen you get your heart broken
way too many times to count this kind of
relationship you have to admit it's 100
not normal yeah it's a big risk and it's
a lot more risk than reward i feel like
when you're looking at it from my eyes
honestly like
i'm 51 now i'm gonna live my life the
way i think i should live my life
without judgment from other people so if
i want to go and marry this dude then
that's on me
this is [ __ ]
let's boy
okay you're entitled to your opinion all
right
jamal's opinion really does mean a lot
to me but i'm still going to do what i
want to do
the love doesn't stop because we don't
get somebody's approval like am i
supposed to just stop loving him and
just walk away
[Music]
you